you get nervous now are you second
guessing yourself are you uh are you too
hard on yourself do you get anxiety what
is it well you know what's interesting
and you're I think because I've I've you
know watched your podcast and listen to
it a lot so I you've talked about this
type of thing always yeah and the thing
is dude in this career
you better accept that sometimes you're
gonna be either the Bellow the ball
you're going to be so improv you're so
important to you're the leader of the
blah blah whatever and then the next
week you can be nobody I mean maybe not
next week but like you alternate from
being someone to no one so you
eventually gotta go it doesn't it
doesn't matter who cares who
cares who cares I get
uncomfortable when when people oh walk
the red carpet I don't want to I don't
want to do it you know what that's funny
you said that I uh I remember my my
manager and I was never good at this go
I want you to go to the Golden Globes
you need to be seen I go I don't have a
project there I don't want to go
somewhere where I don't belong though a
lot of actors go I go I'm not that guy I
went to one Golden Globes and I just
felt weird took my friend it just I
always feel like nobody knows me who am
I what am I doing here I don't belong so
I don't I never did a lot of that and it
might have hurt me he might have been
right I need to do that but a lot of
people can do that I'm not great at it
here's the thing here's the thing your
manager's totally right uh-huh he's
totally right but but you're the guy
again there's there was an episode of of
this where I was just I I was so happy
you were talking about this because you
were breaking open what the reality is
not the
your manager
at that time if he had learned that
Michael Rosenbaum was going to say on a
podcast we're like well yeah no no
you're a big deal and you're the lead
and then you're done and get to the back
of the line yeah that's not what you say
if you're trying to sell the idea of
like this guy's a huge actor he's the
next big thing oh he's really important
yeah you never ever show that you know
because that would be like showing
weakness
vulnerability that's what it is and so
you're encouraged to act like you're
this big important thing
but here's here's my argument by being
honest that's a different thing and that
is really appealing I think to be
completely honest about what this
business is so I have a friend I was
tired of lying on myself for so many
errors I just felt like you know I feel
better just this is who I am this is
what I dealt with this is you know hire
me because
um you think I'm down and I'm and I'm
and I'm easy to work with and so yeah
but go ahead yeah but no but that's the
thing man like like there are people out
there who that message is going to be
far more useful to them so there's the
message of I think people are opening up
to mental health and all that stuff it's
okay we're human yeah yeah you know
something uh that that your
okay when I was finally after Juilliard
after I got kicked out I had to make a
decision whether I was going to pursue
acting or not I'm like okay now I
actually have to decide
and I remember writing on AOL Because
the Internet was brand new so it's like
2 000 or something like that I wrote on
AOL an actor named uh Bruce Campbell do
you know him uh yeah he's right behind
you yeah
so so I wrote Bruce Campbell Bruce
Campbell wrote back and the question was
how do you decide to be an actor and
and he wrote back some of the most
amazing advice you still have it to this
day no no I don't unfortunately but I
remember what he wrote he wrote well
he's like a couple things one
you make the decision and then you don't
look back I'm like that's interesting so
he's saying make a commitment right but
then he said also he's like you know and
also don't expect
that when you get the job that you're
going to be magically happy take the
tools you have right now make yourself
as happy as you can be and I thought
that was such a realistic human way of
thinking about this stuff yeah you know
it's funny I had a conversation with
Bruce not that long ago we were smoking
grass and riding bikes
and he says well
this is my third Act
and I go what he goes It's the Final Act
in his life because he's you know at
that age he's like this is it I got to
do what I want to do this is my last
chance do what I want to do live on my
terms you know
not I'm not doing this kind of
anymore I'm not doing that this is and
we talked about that and it's like you
know there are three acts and I think
you know um I'm in my second act and
it's like you know the third act's
coming up and I want to sort of get a
hold on
you know what I really want I'm spending
so much time trying to figure it out
what it is I really want what do you
want